today we are checking out dji's new fpv
drone this is the dji avada it's 50
lighter has built-in prop guards new
smaller goggles an improved camera and
it can be flown with rc or the motion
controller let's open it up and check it
out
[Music]
here it is
so we've got the goggles and it looks
like the motion controller in this box
and we have the drone in this one
[Music]
let's check out the drone first it's
crazy because this looks so tiny like
the previous dji fpv drone was pretty
awesome but like
this
is so small
oh yeah like if this looks like a legit
fpv drone like one that i would have
went out and built myself
but i didn't
wow oh my goodness oh
this is
so cool i have so much respect for fpv
drone pilots because this right here
what's happening right now opening up a
just pre-built fpv drone that you can go
out and fly that is a privilege that we
now have the ability to do because most
drone pilots create their own like they
start from basically scratch they buy
the parts they build these things they
program themselves and it's like this
mix match of pieces and they make these
incredible flying cameras and today you
know i just opened up a box and i'm
going to put on a headset and i'm going
to go out and fly it is exciting though
that dji is kind of giving people the
ability to experience fpv in a way that
most consumers never really would have
had a chance to do before i do like this
has the built-in prop guard so this is
gonna be so much easier for me to travel
with because the other one was quite
large
got some extra propellers
here we've got the tools to actually
take off the props tiny little screws
oh geez here's everything that comes in
the box we've got our drone a usb-c to
usbc cable we've got an adapter to
charge the battery two propellers a
little tool to screw in the propellers
and the propeller screws all right let's
look at this little guy like check this
out
a little dust on you
oh so dusty so here's the battery and
much like the previous dgi fpv drone it
does
clip in right there so you just plug in
the battery to the drone and this
battery should just pop
right out but not
too easily
because you don't want these to fly out
when you're flying and obviously when
you're flying fpv you're probably flying
pretty aggressively so you definitely
want to have a good
support system and this
is definitely very supportive in there
and right here this is where you can put
your micro sd card and there is also a
usbc all right here's the goggles and
the motion combo pack
look at those
they're so cute
[Music]
these are so much smaller
i cannot wait to fly with these i'm
heading out on a trip here very shortly
i feel like i say that every single time
i open something up and i get to take it
out on adventure this is going to be so
much easier to travel with because it's
so much smaller so looks like we have a
headphone jack a micro sd card slots
usbc and a place to charge i like this
has a little lens protector too
that's cute here's our usbc adapter to
the power adapter so
like the previous version this will plug
into a little external battery to keep
your headset charged here's the motion
controller
this reminds me of the temperature
checks that they give you at the
doctor's office they're just like please
hold
good to go
this looks like a little strap for
the headset here's our battery
oh i like this has a little clip to make
sure that that doesn't pop out
definitely something that you don't want
to happen is if you're out flying and
this usb cable pops out
lost sight of the drone
peace we got a few more things to open
up before we can take this and start
getting it set up
here's our fpv remote controller too
i like this gives you the option of how
you want to fly do you want to fly with
a controller do you want to fly with a
motion controller
yeah this is where i shine i am going to
definitely be trying out the motion
controller to see how that works but i
feel like this is where i'm most
comfortable flying although who says i
can't learn to fly with the motion
controller
that's nice
it's real nice we also have the fly more
kit which will allow us to do just that
fly more we've got additional batteries
and a little charging dock
so we have the charging hub here which
will allow you to charge four different
batteries normally these things don't
charge at the same time it'll just kind
of cycle after one charges the other
will then continue but it will be nice
to be able to just charge these without
worry and set them up overnight in the
morning when you're ready to fly you're
good to go
two extra batteries what a treat how do
we plug oh you plug in with the usb c
port and they did give you one with the
drone so be able to plug that in
we have so many things one last thing to
open up these are the nd filters
there we go
we have nd8 16 and 32.
so now that everything's unboxed i'm
gonna go get the firmware updated get
everything connected and then we can
take this thing out to fly
[Music]
i should have brought a chair but i
basically forgot all the things that i
wanted to bring today so
we have a blanket to sit on
[Music]
so we're outside and we're about to fly
the new dji fpv evada and i'm so excited
i already did fly this for kind of like
my first try in san diego here's a few
clips of that and it was kind of fun
because i just kind of wanted to go out
and kind of get a sense of what this
feels like what it's like to fly see
what the differences are between this
one and the previous version and i met
up with my friend farooq who's also
working on a review video of this drone
i'll put a link in the description if
you want to check out his channel but we
had so much fun and he also gave me the
confidence to try out the motion
controller now this is kind of
interesting because this drone does come
with the motion controller as opposed to
the regular rc controller and at first i
thought i don't like this i don't like
this at all until i actually tried this
out and i was pleasantly surprised how
easy it is to control there are
obviously some maneuvers that you can't
do with this that you could do with the
controller like go backwards so i really
loved trying this out another thing to
note is yes this is an fpv drone and
today i don't think i'm gonna have the
confidence to test it out in manual mode
so there's three different modes there's
normal sport and manual and in manual
mode when you take those little fingers
off those joysticks that drone is going
to fall so i don't feel completely
confident flying in that mode today
which is unfortunate because you can fly
up to 27 meters per second which is
really freaking fast now in sport mode
you can fly 14 meters per second and in
the normal you fly eight and that is a
huge speed difference and it's
interesting because the first time that
i did fly this it did feel like it was
going a little bit slower than i thought
that it would and that my friends is
because we were in sport and normal so
if you really do want to use this to its
full potential get comfortable get cozy
with flying fpv and you can really take
advantage of that i really do need to
work on my skills because i don't want
to lose this before i finish this video
so let's get this prepped and out there
and ready to fly
[Music]
they also came with some nd filters so
i'm going to pop on an nd filter since
it is a little bit bright so i'm gonna
see what that looks like i didn't get a
chance to try out the nd filters in san
diego so we'll see what the difference
looks like
here's our little nd filters look at you
you're so cute we've got an nd8 16 and
32.
[Music]
so here's the headset here's our
antennas and this has a nice little eye
protector which is actually quite nice
the thing that i really like about the
headset so far is that this is a little
touch pad right here so this is how you
kind of control the settings and access
the menu pretty intuitive and it has
like a little raised bump right here so
you'll be able to know where the center
of that is here's my gripe with this
headset
it's much lighter but they did not put a
top little head strap on so you have to
tighten this pretty tight around your
head and when i was in san diego after i
got done filming i had an indentation
across my forehead for at least 10 hours
like it finally has dissipated today
which is great because
it was ridiculous so what i've decided
to do is i brought a headband i have two
of them i brought this one here which is
a little bit aggressive but i think that
this might alleviate the indentation
this look nice
do i look like an official drone pilot
let's see how this feels this actually
feels great this feels so much better it
is a little bit heavier on the bridge of
my nose it really needs to have a top
head strap like there's no doubt about
that you kind of look like
cyclops from next one
i'm available for hire phone is
connected
goggles are on
okay ready
there i am i look so stupid with this
headband on
[Music]
here we go
whoa
that was so close to you
was it really close to you
oh my god
okay we did it
first flight here in palos verde is done
um so this seems like it feels nice a
little extra padding but now it's
pressing on my nose but man that was so
fun
wow wow i freaking love it i do feel
like the first version of these i felt
way more motion sickness every time i'd
fly so far i've felt actually perfect
maybe that's the trade-off dent in your
forehead no motion sickness swapping out
batteries then to show you guys the
motion controller and how much fun this
thing is battery swap out these last
about 19 minutes which for a drone is
still not bad i mean obviously we wish
the drones would have longer battery
life but you know it is what it is still
it's not bad i have three batteries
so that gives me plenty of time to test
looks like our nd filter has survived
okay buddy you ready for your next ride
here's our motion controller this
basically works with just that you
guessed it motion so we have this big
button here which is our break this
switches our modes this is how you
basically start the motors take off and
land this is a tilt and then this is a
little button to press to start and stop
your recording which i'm going to
hopefully
not forget to press because i always
seem to forget to record now this is fun
because this will basically let you
control this drone
with just one hand so i'm gonna start
recording already
so i don't forget
headsets going on now the problem that i
have with these goggles is around the
edges there's definitely
it's
a little bit blurry so it makes it kind
of hard to see things that are on the
edge but everything is pretty crisp and
clear in the center and to adjust
there's these little knobs down at the
bottom which will allow you to kind of
move the eye pieces
depending upon how
your eyes are connected
recording we're going to stay in normal
mode and once i get it up then we'll go
to sport
and here we go okay this is how we
control up down
left right
and to accelerate
you pull the trigger
so here we go
that's it we're driving
we're driving we're cruising
it's so fun
it's like a whole different way to fly
if you've never used the motion
controller before
it's pretty awesome like you could just
cruise down
we're cruising now we're going we're
going we're cruising
thankfully there's any surfers out here
that i could accidentally hit so we're
in normal mode right now so we're going
to switch to
sport
so here she goes
oh my gosh it's so fast it's so much
faster it's basically double the speed
oh my god i'm so close to the ground so
close to the ground so close to the
ground so close to the ground i'm so
scared
oh god those leaves really
were close somebody got a haircut
this is so fun
it's so weird looking at myself outside
of my body like this is an actual true
out-of-body experience
[Music]
oh so dusty we did it
didn't crash this was a very successful
flight i've been having so much fun
checking out this drone my foot is
asleep oh gosh most of this video i was
shooting it in sport mode which will get
us about 13 to 14 meters per second
which is still pretty fast little drone
look at you you're looking pretty dusty
but you did a great job today little
buddy so like i said the beginning of
this video this will go into full manual
mode and with that you're able to
actually fly this like a real true fpv
drone so if you do take your fingers off
those joysticks it will fall from the
sky so you need to be fully prepared for
that
so comparing this to the previous
version is kind of interesting because
of the size difference like i feel like
this is so much more portable and
compact like you can take this more
places also the handling was a little
bit different i did feel like with the
previous version i was able to maneuver
a little bit faster and a little bit
quicker in sport mode but one of the
things that i liked about this is yes
you can use the motion controller in the
previous version but i did not actually
test that out fully in the previous one
so this is kind of my first time testing
out the motion controller and one of the
things that's interesting is with this
this does come with the motion
controller it doesn't come with the rc
controller so if you are getting one of
these you would have to get the rc
separately using the motion controller
was one of the more surprising things
because this does come with it i really
wanted to make sure i tested that out to
see what that is like and i was
pleasantly surprised it does kind of
give you an all new way to fly and i
feel like i would probably use that if i
was just kind of doing a casual going
out to fly whereas the rc controller
that gives me a little bit more precise
movements and that's obviously what i'm
more familiar with you can also go
backwards using the rc controller but
you cannot fly backwards using the
motion controller so i think for a lot
of people if you are used to flying with
an rc you might be surprised how cool
the motion controller actually is thank
you guys so much for watching i'll put a
link in the description if you want to
check out the new dji fpv ovada i had a
lot of fun getting a chance to fly this
and i look forward to flying this more
i'm also very glad that this is a lot
smaller because this is going to be way
easier to travel with with that my
friends i will see you in my next video
if you haven't already please subscribe
hit the bell to be notified when i post
new videos and i will see you guys in
the next one leave me some comments
below and let me know where you would
like to fly a drone at where would you
love to go travel to and explore see in
the next video bye
[Music]
does anybody want to take some guesses
how long the indentation will last on my
head is it bad okay so it's not even
that bad this is nothing compared to
what it was before
[Music]